Hollywood has turned out some
regrettable remakes over the years but
among the garbage there have also been
some successful cinematic revivals like
Ocean's eleven and the thing both of
which made audiences forget there was
something else to compare them to in the
first place with that optimistic outlook
in mind let's take a look at all the
remakes Tinseltown has in the works that
might be worth your ticket money
Suspiria 1977 Suspiria has been
described as a nightmare fairy tale HD
neon colors the horror film focused on
an American ballerina who arrives at a
European Dance Academy only to find
herself in serious trouble when the
students start dying in disturbing ways
it's as good as Italian horror cinema
gets and remaking it seems like an
impossible task but Luca Guadagnino is
going to try anyway the Italian
filmmaker is working with an impressive
roster of great actresses including
Dakota Johnson Tilda Swinton Chloe grace
Moretz and Mia goth and even Jessica
Harper the star of the original will
make a cameo in the new iteration the
biggest difference we'll see is in the
color choices involved in the remake
while the original is perhaps the most
colorful horror film ever put to
celluloid what Annie know says his take
will have no primary colors instead to
prepare yourself for a film that's
winter ish evil and really dark dirty
rotten scoundrels 1988 dirty rotten
scoundrels was a classic comedy starring
Michael Caine and Steve Martin as 2 con
men who made a rather despicable wager
the two were trying to fleece an heiress
out of her money and whoever lost the
bet had to skip town but while the film
was a success the story was hardly
original dirty rotten scoundrels was
actually a remake of a 1964 film called
bedtime story which starred marlon
brando MGM is currently updating the
movie again with women in the lead
instead the new pic nasty women will
star Anne Hathaway and rebel Wilson as
two despicable scammers if nasty women
manages to bring back the whole cultured
crook versus crass con artist angle then
it's not difficult to guess who will
play her
overboard released in 1987 Gabi marshals
overboard may have divided critics but
it eventually won the hearts of comedy
fans around the world starring the
legendary couple of Kurt Russell and
Goldie Hawn the film focused on a
spoiled heiress who fell off a yacht and
woke up in a hospital with amnesia
through a series of hijinks her
carpenter tricked her into thinking she
was his wife and hillbilly hell broke
out well you you were crumpled I
flash-forward three decades and
overboard is being remade with Anna
Faris and a haenyeo debase in the lead
roles but this time there's a twist the
roles will be flipped with two BAE's
playing a selfish playboy from a wealthy
Mexican family who loses his memory
after taking a tumble off a boat while
Ferris will be a single mom who falls
Derby's into thinking he's her husband
when in doubts gender swap adults the
Thomas Crown Affair coming off films
like Creed and Fruitvale station
there's no denying Michael B Jordan is
one of the most exciting actors working
today now he'll be following in Steve
McQueen's footsteps with another
adaptation of the Thomas Crown Affair
the original 1968 film followed a
wealthy businessman who orchestrated a
nearly perfect bank robbery but
eventually an insurance investigator
began to suspect crown of pulling off
the heist sparks eventually flew between
them and the two leads had to grapple
with both their emotions and millions of
dollars as they try to outwit one
another the film was already remade with
some success with Pierce Brosnan and
Rene Russo as the co-leads
but what's really impressive is that
this new version is all Michael B
Jordans idea
Jordan reportedly pitched MGM on the
idea for a remake himself and landed the
title role as a result the raid
redemption one of the craziest action
movies in recent memory the raid
redemption followed a SWAT team trying
to nab a notorious crime lord but most
of the movie was made up of fantastic
fight scenes as the team battles away up
a heavily guarded high-rise apartment
building however while the original raid
is a martial arts extravaganza director
Joe Carnahan plans on getting grittier
with his upcoming remake the director of
films like narc and the gray car
is teaming up with actor Frank Grillo to
create a film he says will feel like a
feature-length version of the knife
fight scene in Saving Private Ryan
Deathwish the quintessential revenge
flick Michael winners death wish I saw a
pacifist turned killer declare war on
New York criminals after a gang of thugs
murdered his wife and raped his daughter
while the film stirred up quite a bit of
controversy back in the day death wish
was financially successful enough to
spawn several sequels what's the problem
now over 40 years later MGM has decided
to remake the dirty and gritty thriller
and possibly start a new series only
this time a Bruce Willis will be playing
the part of Paul Kersey
instead of Charles Bronson and Eli Roth
will step behind the camera for the
flick according to Roth we can expect to
see hostile style torture scenes with a
spectacular set pieces on this remake so
get ready to lose your appetite because
always comes true an American Werewolf
in London when it comes to werewolves
there's one film that stands snout and
shoulders above the rest an American
Werewolf in London is the quintessential
lycanthrope flick so universals upcoming
remake has some pretty big paw prints to
fill David Alpert and Robert Kirkman of
The Walking Dead Fame are set to produce
the new American werewolf bringing some
serious horror cred to the project
meanwhile Universal is keeping things in
the family on the filmmaking side hoping
to recapture the black magic of the
original the studio has brought out max
Landis
the son of the originals writer and
director John Landis to pen the
screenplay and helm the film so
hopefully this won't be just another bad
moon movie on the rise the great
outdoors one of John Hughes lesser-known
scripting efforts the great outdoors was
a 1988 comedy starring John candy as
Chet Ripley a Chicagoan who just wants
to spend some time with his family out
on the Wisconsin wilderness
unfortunately Chet's relaxing vacation
was ruined when his annoying
brother-in-law crashed the party with
his own family in tow leading to a
series of escapades involving water skis
a giant steak
and the bald-headed bear now Universal
Pictures is aiming to reboot the film
with Kevin Hart on board to lead whether
he plays chert or his brother-in-law
remains to be seen but we can count on
the funny man to deliver some memorable
moments and remind everyone what an
underrated gem the original was Scarface
say hello to a little remake of this
gangster classic as one of Al Pacino's
most acclaimed performances it's no
wonder fans are a bit skeptical about
anyone touching Brian De Palma's 1983
film but what most people don't know is
that Scarface was actually a remake
itself the first Scarface was filmed in
1932 and it featured an Italian
immigrant making a name for himself in
the Chicago mob a couple of decades
later the Pomo simply switched the
setting to Miami turns the main
character into a Cuban and created an
all-time masterpiece in keeping with the
Scarface we make tradition the new film
will take place in Los Angeles and
follow a Mexican immigrants rise to
power Diego Luna will play the main
character working with a screenplay
written by boardwalk Empire's Terence
winter and doctored by the Coen brothers
you might recall that the last time the
sibling duo had anything to do with a
script about drugs murder and Mexican
cartels it worked out pretty well so
maybe we should be optimistic about
Scarface as modern-day revival the
intouchables when the intouchables made
its way to America in 2012 the film was
not a commercial success but overseas
this French drama made an absolute
killing the story focused on the
relationship between a paralyzed man
named Philippe and his Senegalese
caretaker dress in addition to race the
two are separated by class and the
different world views but over the
course of the film
the two form a bond and help each other
become better people now The Weinstein
Company is giving Americans another
chance to see the movie only this time
they'll get to hear all the dialogue in
English retitled untouchable the
upcoming remake will star Bryan Cranston
as a wheelchair-bound Philip and Kevin
Hart will play Dell Phillips new
assistant from the Bronx Nicole Kidman
will also star and Neil Berger will
direct the pick or bow in two theaters
and March 2018 Starship Troopers
directed by Paul Verhoeven
starship troopers has never gotten the
same amount of love as the door
des magnum opus Robocop but it still
gained a sizable cult following over the
years the 1997 original followed a group
of kids who joined the military to fight
the bugs in outer space
initially the movie was misunderstood by
quite a few critics but these days
troopers has widely recognized as a
biting satire on fascism the original
novel written by Robert a Heinlein
couldn't be more different the book has
a much more Pro War stance than of a
joven film which means the upcoming
remake or diverge significantly Columbia
Pictures hopes to kick off a potential
franchise with a new Starship Troopers
but most importantly the upcoming
version will stick a lot closer to the
novel maniac cop directed by the
infamous William Lustig 1988 maniac cop
has been described as lucky and scummy
and actually kind of fun the
exploitation flick features Tom Atkins
as a cop investigating a series of
murders
Robert Sedaris a psychopathic police
officer killing anyone in his path and
the Bruce Campbell as an innocent cop
caught in the middle while the film
wasn't exactly a critical hits the
slasher had picked up a cult following
over the years the maniac cop remake has
been in the works since 2012 but in 2015
things really started moving Marvel and
DC Comics writer edy frou Baker is
writing the script with John Hyams
directing in March 2017 Variety reported
that the film would start shooting in
the summer
although the remake isn't going to be
exactly the same as the stig's original
B picture this time Maniac Cop will be
more of a realistic thriller than a
horror film with producer Nicolas
Winding raffinate Elling a Bloody
Disgusting the new film will serve as
more of a commentary on modern day
society and the sometimes questionable
actions of law enforcement there's no
word yet on who's starring but whoever
they pick they all probably pale in
comparison to Cumberlands Adar at least
when it comes to their chins anyway
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Applause]